Hello.
I'm now going to use the actual
Khan Academy website to
do some more problems.
And this time we're going to
go the other way around.
We're going to look at the
graph of a trigonometric
function and we're going to try
to figure out the equation.
So let's start with the problem
we have in front of us.
So we have a-- well we don't
know if it's a sine curve or a
cosine curve, but I guess it's
fair to say that it's
one of the two.
Actually, let's answer
that question first.
What do you think this is?
Do you think that this is a
sine curve or a cosine curve?
What's the difference?
Or what's the easiest
difference to differentiate
between the two?
Well, what was sine of 0?
Let me get a little
chalkboard in here.
Let me bring it right here.
Let me make sure my
pen tool is correct.
All right.
What is sine of 0?
And it could be 0
degrees or 0 radians.
Well if you remember from a
couple of the other modules,
or even if you want to use a
calculator, sine of 0 is 0.
And what is cosine of 0?
Well cosine of 0, if you
remember from the last modules
or you want to use a
calculator-- although you
shouldn't have to use a
calculator for cosine of 0--
you might remember
that it was 1.
So this graph that we have
here, it's definitely when x is
0, when the x-axis is 0, the
function definitely isn't 0.
In fact, in this
case it's 1 1/2.
So this tells us that this
isn't a sine curve-- although
later with shifts we'll learn
that it could be a shifted sine
curve-- that this isn't a sine
curve, that this is
a cosine curve.
And then you might ask, well
Sal if this is a cosine curve
why is f of 0 equal to 1
1/2, or 3/2, instead of 1?
Because I just said here
that cosine of 0 is 1.
Well that's because there must
be some type of a coefficient
here, let's call it A, that is
changing the amplitude
of this cosine curve.
And if you remember from
the last module, what
do you think this A is?
Well that A is just literally
the amplitude of the curve.
And what's the amplitude
of this curve?
Well, the amplitude of this
curve, if we just see how much
it moves above and below the
x-axis, well it's that 3/2,
or that 1 1/2, we've
been talking about.
See it moves up 3/2,
and it moves down 3/2.
So let me just write that.
So we know that this is 3/2
cosine of, well, something x.
Right?
We know f of x is equal to
3/2 cosine of something x.
And we could use the formula
that we learned in the previous
video, that it equals
2pi over the period x.
So now we just have to look at
the graph and try to figure
out what the period
of the graph is.
Well how many radians does
it take for the graph to
start repeating again?
Let me click on the
hint button, and maybe
this'll help us.
When I click hint--
there; drew the period.
And you could have figured
it out on your own.
If you just go from any point
and then follow the curve back
to the same point again, you'll
see how long it's period is.
And the hint on the Khan
icon actually told us
that the period is 4pi.
And you could just start from
any point to any other point.
You could have gone from this
point and then gone down,
gone back up, come down.
And then you would have seen
that this distance is also 4pi.
So we know that the
period is 4pi.
And then I could click hint
again and it'll tell us stuff
that we already figured out.
The amplitude, we already
figured out, was 1 1/2.
But let's just use a period,
because we already knew
what the amplitude is.
So the period here we already
figured out was 4pi.
So let's just write
that in our equation.
So f of x is equal to 3/2
cosine of 2pi divided by
the period-- the period
in this case is 4pi-- x.
That equals 3/2
cosine of 1/2 x.
Now if you ever forget this
formula, which frankly
I always do forget it.
I've actually never
memorized it.
I just try to think about
what the period would be.
The way I think about it is the
coefficient on the x-term,
that's a measure of how
many cycles does the graph
do within 2pi radians.
Let me see if I can explain
that within the context
of this problem.
So this problem, if we start at
0 and then 2pi is here, how
many cycles do we complete
by the time we get to 2pi?
We start here, we go back
here, and then we're at 2pi.
Well we only got halfway
done through a cycle.
So that's the coefficient
on the x-term.
And that's how I remember it.
So I could just say, well
that's 3/2 cosine of
how many cycles do I
complete in 2pi radians?
Well I only complete
half a cycle.
3/2 times the cosine of 1/2 x.
So that's our f of x.
Let's do another problem.
All right.
OK.
This one's interesting.
So the first thing, just by
inspection we can figure out
what this amplitude is.
This is pretty easy.
Right?
How much does it move above
and below the x-axis?
Well it only goes 1, so we know
that the coefficient, or the
multiplier times the sine
or the cosine function--
whichever this is-- is 1.
So let's write that down.
Let's write down that the
amplitude is equal to 1.
Now let's try to figure
out if this is a sine
or a cosine function.
In the last problem we
said sine of 0 is 0
and cosine of 0 is 1.
Well f of 0 of this function,
whichever it is, is 0.
So we know this is a
non-shifted sine function.
So there.
We have another piece
of information.
It's a sine function.
So the last thing we have to
figure out, we can either
figure out the period or we
could use the method that I
just showed you where we say,
well how many times does it
cycle within 2pi radians?
So let's do it that way.
And then we immediately
know the coefficient.
Let's see.
Well actually, this graph
board doesn't even get
all the way to 2pi.
But let's see.
It goes one cycle, two cycles.
And I did two cycles in
only pi radians, right?
Because I'm only at
x equals pi here.
So if I did two cycles in pi
radians, then we must be able
to do four cycles
in 2pi radians.
Or we could actually
start here.
Actually, this is better.
Right?
Going from negative pi to pi.
That's 2pi radians.
So we finish one cycle,
two cycles, three
cycles, four cycles.
So then we know what the
coefficient on the x-term is.
So we know that it
is sine of 4x.
So the answer here is f of x is
equal to 1-- because that's the
amplitude-- the amplitude
times sine of 4x.
I think we have
time for one more.
And I want you to-- don't just
mechanically do whatever
I'm telling you.
I want you to think about why
counting the number of cycles
within 2pi radians, why
that makes sense to you.
Then think back to
the unit circle.
Or think back why that formula,
the 2pi divided by the period,
is also the coefficient.
Think about why
that makes sense.
If you realize why it makes
sense you'll never have to
memorize it, and then 20 years
later when you're doing it like
I'm doing it right now
you won't be confused.
You'll be able to
re-derive the formulas.
Let's do one more.
All right.
So what's the amplitude here?
Well, let's see.
The amplitude is 1/2.
So let me delete the old stuff
that I was writing before.
For some reason
it's not deleting.
OK.
Hope I don't confuse you.
So the amplitude, let's
just call it Amplitude,
is equal to 1/2.
And how many cycles does it
complete within 2pi radians?
Let's see.
If we start here it looks like
it completes only half a cycle.
Right?
Because it takes 4pi radians
to complete the entire cycle.
So it only completes
half a cycle.
So we could think of
it either two ways.
We could say that the period is
equal to 4pi, because that's
how long it takes to complete
one cycle, or we could say
it can only complete half a
cycle within 2pi radians.
The last thing we have to
figure out: Is it a sine
or a cosine function?
Well, f of 0 is 0.
Right?
So it's a non-shifted
sine function.
So then we're done.
We have f of x is equal to
1/2-- figured out it's a sine
function-- sine of what?
How many cycles did it
complete in 2pi radians?
It only completed half a cycle.
Let me not cover the problem.
It only completes half a cycle.
So it's 1/2 sine of 1/2 x.
Or we could use the formula f
of x equals goes 1/2 sine of
2pi divided by the period x.
Right?
Because 2pi divided by the
period is equal to 2pi over
4pi, which also equals 1/2.
I think that'll give you
a sense of how to do
these problems now.
And I encourage you to
practice them on the
Khan Academy website.
Have fun.